here you are in New York City leading up
to your birthday honey I know Saint
Tamar's day
now you were telling me good things
happened on your birthday magical thing
okay so what's being manifested what's
happening right now leading up to you
well I'm super excited that I'm putting
out my first single yes yes that I have
yeah I mean seven years six years I lost
count no three three years I know we've
been wondering because yeah there were
two albums coming out yes and so what's
the hold up what's cooking you got the
single coming out so tell us about a
little bit of the the vision behind this
music the vibe um you know I just had to
speak about what I was going through and
yes well I was single for a very very
long time looking for love being let
down
um and trying to figure out where I fit
you know with love and um I had to write
about that so love is inspiring love is
and inspiring me good and bad okay okay
I mean it is that's the thing about
dating you can always get a good story
you know hello thank you for the
research darling honey there are some
there are a lot of frogs out there yes
there is
uh with your music since you're putting
something out there well this then like
a full album or those two albums follow
up this single very very shortly okay
very shortly the record is called
changed and I'm really proud of it
because this is the first time in the
long time that I've been this excited
about music really yes so this phase in
your life the evolution that you've
undergone you've been working on
yourself for quite some time and when we
last spoke that was at the Forefront of
your mind is just making sure that you
were okay you were being in tune with
your feelings your emotion where you are
in life how has your music helped this
this phase of your life this Evolution
and how you're feeling it's been
incredibly healing you know because you
know how when people are in a therapy
they often speak about journaling but
this is me journaling and you know
putting my thoughts and my biggest fears
or my hopes my dreams on a piece of
paper and I get to you know verbalize it
by singing your birthday is bringing us
the music so that's the gift to us fans
yeah for sure what other good things are
coming I mean let's just talk about love
can we just go ahead and talk about some
Queen schools let's talk about the
Queen's car first up was like when I
heard okay we're gonna sit down with
Tamar about Queen's Court I was like is
is she pulling a Judge Judy on me
obviously I got further into it this is
a reality a dating show so why are you
going down this Lane I feel like you
just can't shake some reality TV for
some reason so why are you coming back
and going down the dating well you know
look I had to find Mr Right somewhere
I'm just looking for that
something I can't shake
damn 21 man you're gonna have to pray
for us we're ready I feel like I've
looked high and low and the truth is I
wanted to meet you know some potentials
you know in a different kind of way you
know because normally in this business
you meet people through people yeah and
I think I don't ran out of people
the rolodexes is out you know you've
already run through the role of the day
so here you are you've got like this
love hate relationship with reality I do
so how did you fare with this one well
you know I have a love hate relationship
with irresponsible reality television
okay will Packer who is amazing and
responsible and he's a producer who is
true to his word and um so when he
called me about this show I was very
hesitant number one I was going to be
dating publicly in front of the world
right uh number two it was reality
television but something told me to
trust the process and I've never done
anything like this before and what's the
worst that can happen I find love well
here you have it I don't know so did you
find that well you have to tune in okay
but the good thing about tuning in this
time is that you get a whole drop so you
get to binge on 10 episodes you don't
have to wait week by week and you get to
see right then and there on Thursday
March 16th a day before our saint tamars
day I told you magical things happened
we get two gifts we get two gifts
um listen this TV show is so amazing
it's one of my most proudest moments
really seriously outside of Big Brother
it is well because I got a chance to
really be with some girlfriends people I
really truly love and respect who was
looking for the same thing that I was
looking for we had vulnerable moments
we've had amazing moments and funny
moments
right yeah crying laughing so hard at
some points I feel like we're gonna get
a lot of memes out of this yes you are
does he make your spirit jump or your
future we also get three queens you do
we get 21 potential I'm not even gonna
say Kings everyone eligible bachelors
there we go so we get a lot of spice in
there you get your I mean it runs the
gamut with the guys that they bring in
for you yeah from groupies to meditators
to
professionals professionals to players
the players from the Himalayas honey I
mean a couple you compare one to Nick
Cannon and you ask another in one of
your confessionals if he's gonna take
you to Chuck E cheese
well hey this that's what dating looks
like in 2023 you never know what you're
gonna get true you know and and the
great thing about it is that the 21 Men
came to us and we didn't have to go and
find them which is the hardest thing
yeah about dating these days but you had
to approach them and to ask them hey
will you go on a date with me that was
tough yeah that was tough because I'm
old-fashioned and I'm stuck in my ways
but you know I mean that's a part of
putting yourself out there and choosing
the right one you know sometimes we wait
for the person to ask us and it's all
wrong right so this time you know I get
to have conversations and choose my own
day the balls in tamars
so what exactly did you learn about
yourself through the process of this
journey well the number one thing that I
learned is that I wasn't as ready as I
said that I was in receiving love and
receiving love really yes yes I had how
was that revealed to you well because
um the times when a certain amount of
gentlemen will show me some type of
affection I didn't want it yeah
um sometimes when they wouldn't want to
have certain conversations I wasn't open
yeah and um I just had to really check
myself and make sure that you know this
is the area that I had to work on before
I you know just branched myself out a
little bit further I can't understand
you are a woman of certain notoriety and
you think probably you put up these
defense mechanisms because you don't
want people's motives or no and you
never know and sometimes you never know
until you need to eat and then it's too
late yeah yeah and at this big age I
don't want to make the same mistakes
for an amazing partner a good friend
a good bonus person to my son you know
someone who I can bounce ideas off of
and grow with and grow old with and you
know a for lifer that's what I'm looking
for yeah and if marriage is part of the
equation great great this is not okay so
speaking of Mr Logan here he's almost
dead almost 10. so what did he make of
Mama going on a reality show today oh
well at first he was not here for it
really yes um and the biggest thing
about you know being a single mother to
a son they want us to find
a man they really do he does he really
truly wanted me to find my my life
partner and I had to remind him like
well you know Mommy can't find him in
the house with you you're gonna have to
go that's when you opened up to the idea
because ultimately our children wants us
to be happy that's comforting you know
to know that it's not something that
he's holding against you or a grudge or
nope although he's picky well that's a
good thing
he wants me to be happy what about your
exes have they weighed in on you taking
part in a reality dating show uh yes we
have what was their tube sense well the
first one
um he's very overprotective he's really
definitely taking the role as Big
Brother which is very weird but okay
yeah because he's a family member and so
his his biggest thing was for me to be
careful about motives and other people's
objectives
um because he took one sweet to find
love and he was very very supportive and
the second one was like I have no idea
what you're doing and why you're doing
this
you are leading me on this path to find
hello
Mommy in the situation anyway exactly
exactly and I also love that Holly and
Rodney
you know hosting navigating this ship
with y'all probably just seems like one
of the girls and I also love seeing the
relationships it seems that you formed
with Evelyn and maybe because you're a
girl that has grown up with a house full
of sisters and this just seems to be
like another extension of that and I
have two more yeah two more bonus
sisters well three more bonus sisters
and a brother yes um listen the
relationships
I I think surpass all of my
understanding as to what I truly needed
in that moment yeah I needed Evelyn I
needed Nivea I needed Rodney I needed
Holly in that moment in my life to
really funnel through all of my biggest
fears yes so even if Tamar's not walking
away with a man she walked away with
four oh lifelong friends and Holly and
Rodney was such a huge blessing because
they have been through it and they were
very open about you know their
challenges and their relationship and it
really did help us um that the person
that we were supposed to end up with or
not
foreign